مباشره لا شرم الشيخ ونشاهد هذه الصور
للقاء الذي يجمع الرئيسين الامريكي جوبايد
الذي وصلت قبل قليل المشاركه في انفعاليات
قمه شرم الشيخ 27 ورئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه التي تستضيف هذه
القمه والتي تناقش الكثير من الملفات
المتعلقه
بالبيئه في قمه ايضا ينظر اليها الكثير
وخاصه المراقبين لمجال الطاقه والبيئه على
انها قمه مهمه وحساسه وتاتي في ضرب الدقيق
البعض يعني يصفها بقمه الفرصه الاخيره
لانقاذ البشريه كما يقول البعض اللي في
ضوء طبعا همم
الانبعاث الحراري والدرجه التي وصلت اليها
حراره الارض وهمم
التطورات ايضا المناخيه التي همم او
التحديات التي شهدتها او شهدت بعض دول
العالم خاصه في اوروبا كما ركبنا وتابعنا
في الاشهر الاخيره اذا وصول الرئيس
الامريكي
الى قمه شرم الشيخ للمشاركه في هذه القمه
من المنتظر
الرئيس الامريكي
همم في على مهام شادي القمه
وخاصه يعني في ضوء المؤشرات والتحديات
التي يمر بها العالم مناقيا
كانت قمه شرم الشيخ قد ايه بدات في الايام
القليله الماضيه
باللقاءات وكذلك الكثير من الفعاليات
والخطابات والكثير من الجلسات ايضا التي
تمت على هامش هذه الامل